tonight we look at how one school is
going to extreme measures to keep its
students and faculty stay safe here's
correspondent Doug mackelway school
shooters are not unlike the asymmetrical
fighters of guerilla war or terrorists
their power to strike widespread fear
and grief is out of proportion to their
strength a fact that is complicating the
on-going debates about how intrusive and
how costly school security should be one
company is sparing no expense using
$400,000 of its own money Virginia based
net talent has funded a test school in
Indiana teachers wearing wireless key
fobs can activate a system of alerts
smoke canisters and other undisclosed
countermeasures of deployed bulletproof
doors and windows are locked and areas
contained this is all done automatically
this school is wired directly securely
to the Sheriff's Department ten miles
away so the Sheriff's Department can
monitor in real-time of anybody inside
with a gun that can take on the man
that's right outside the door by the way
can shoot right through the steel doors
the president's apparent skepticism is
matched by other doubts $400,000 to
fortify a school is prohibitive for many
costs trapped districts in addition some
psychologists believe that beefed up
security might encourage some profoundly
troubled shooters it increases the drama
it increases the spectacle imagine that
you're designing a movie set the place
is swarming with armed guards to someone
who has a pathological fantasy of
destruction that just ups the challenge
Florida is taking a different route with
plans to empower students with an app
called fortify Florida so many kids now
are on snapchat Instagram and they need
a uniform way to report that also with
the condition of anonymity some feared
could swap authorities with petty
reports unknown risk evidenced by the
failure to act on the many warnings
about Nicholas Cruz one promising area
his threat assessment based on a u.s.
Secret Service model it would compile
data on at-risk individuals including
any record of domestic workplace and
school violence as well as arson
sabotage and other warning signs our
focus is on how to train the teachers
say
members the community the bartenders the
hair stylists on how to spot concerning
behavior and then how to report it to
diminished fears of a surveillance state
threat assessment professionals say the
data would be used only to warn into
council families friends and teachers of
a troubled person not to intrude on
civil liberties Brent Doug thank you